hallo mein name ist lupo meine lieben
freunde ihr seht es bereits im titel
eingeblendet und das ist wirklich nicht
untertrieben die spieler heute das
wirklich realistische spiel aller zeiten
namens teardown auf den allerersten
blick sieht ihr dann erst mal aus wie
eine mischung aus gta 4 weil wir uns
hier in new york befinden und minecraft
weil alles so ein bisschen sonne blog
optik hat plus wir unten rechts in der
hand einer axt halten das ist auch
irgendwie so die richtige beschreibung
hierfür denn wir haben zuvor kreierte
maps sowie bei gta allerdings auch
diesen minecraft look mit diesen ganzen
blöcken überall und der möglichkeit
alles mögliche zu zerstören
und ihr seht allerdings auch schon das
ist nicht so wie bei minecraft ist das
wenn ich hier drauf haut
das ding irgendwie weg ist und ich
kriege das inventar nein
ich kann hier immer weiter drauf hauen
und es geht immer weiter kaputt wissen
wir schlussendlich
ganz kleine würfelchen haben und alles
einzeln hier liegt
irgendwann dies ist natürlich auch weil
hier nicht alles vorliegen kann mit
irgendwelchen kleinen krönchen guckt
dass ich dir jetzt hier vorne schon aber
wir haben wirklich die möglichkeit alles
mögliche zu verändern und wir schauen
uns diese map jetzt erst mal noch ein
bisschen weiter an wir können wirklich
alles möglich zerstören doch das hier
zum baum ist beispielsweise ob das der
bogen ist oder auch wenn das hier
beispielsweise irgendwie diese teile zum
beispiel nicht dass so wie bei gta du
kannst mit dem auto dagegen fahren ganz
menschen rum fahren andere autos keine
ahnung was aber wenn du gegen sonntag
erst dann ist vorbei wir können
allerdings auch beispielsweise bei
solchen häusern einfach mal die fenster
rausschmeißen
oder wir machen es einfach mal ein
bisschen krasser und fliegen rüber zum
one world trade center das neuro und
rechts haben wie übrigens auch
gesundheit allerdings sieht es hier beim
one world trade center wirklich noch ein
bisschen krasser aus ich fliege jetzt
einfach mal hoch und kann hierbei frau
schlagen
dann seht ihr nämlich fällt das wirklich
den ganzen weg von oben runter
und das ist besonders hier kraft weil
das ja komplett aus glas ist oder
beispielsweise auch bei dem hier
oder auch hier bei diesen häusern das
ist wirklich so geil
und ich weiß nicht ob ich der einzige
bin der auf seiner tik tok von jupiter
mal solche video vorgeschlagen bekommt
und ich weiß auch nicht ob das wirklich
nur so ein junges ding jetzt aber ich
zum beispiel fans so seite fallen wenn
ich jetzt beispielsweise einfach mal
hoch fliegen hier was rauskommt und das
liegt ganz weit runter und dann
unten irgendwo rauf allerdings ist dass
sie die new york mit meiner liebe
freunde wir sehen auf jeden fall einige
sachen die wir in new york auch so
feststellen können zum beispiel das hier
ist der apple store
[Musik]
war der apple stores oben drin hatte
tommy hilfiger eine wohnung das ist mit
einer der teuersten wohnungen in new
york die können wir auch einfach mal
zerstören kay tommy
habe die sache noch nie gemocht hier
vorne haben wir das essex house da kann
man auf jeden fall auch ein paar sachen
machen das jetzt der columbus circle
hier war ich mal in einem hotel da kommt
man extrem geil hier über den central
park gucken wir haben hier verschiedene
sachen das ding habe ich nie verstanden
das finde ich so verwirrend dieses
gebäude die haben extra alle paar
stockwerke luft lassen müssen damit das
ding nicht umfällt
damit der winter
durchgehend kann
ich finde so sein ist einfach nur sachen
zerstört allerdings wäre ich natürlich
nicht laser luca bin ich nicht auch noch
ein paar andere maps vorbereitet hätte
wie beispielsweise diese hier dass sie
ist die voxel plaza am app ich habe euch
generell mal so ein paar sachen und in
die beschreibung gepackt wenn ihr euch
das auch herunterladen wollte und hier
sieht es wirklich noch mal deutlich
krasser aus also wir haben hier
natürlich nicht so eine riesige web wie
die new york mets allerdings ist alles
ein bisschen mehr mit liebe zum detail
wir sehen den ganzen schnee die auch
hier angedeutet wird und wir können
jetzt hier beispielsweise licht anmachen
und können und dann ein bisschen
umgucken und das alles hier so als
baustelle uns begutachten
[Musik]
den sieg in den später 8
ich kann aber jetzt sicher der schaufel
auf
also ich habe hier vorne jetzt das
komplette haus eigentlich untergraben
und alles mögliche an wänden oder
stehenden materialien ja einfach mal
entsorgt das können wir uns jetzt noch
mal ganz kurz angucken wenn ich hier den
bagger verlasse das sollte eigentlich
zusammenbrechen ich weiß ja dass jetzt
wegen wie dadurch und da vorne noch
gehalten wird aber in dieser map ist es
auf jeden fall auch möglich alles
mögliche zu zerstören ich habe auch
immer noch die minecraft modifikation
installiert dass ich hier vorne so ein
bisschen herum fliegen kann kann ich
auch ein bagger speichern ein paar
sekunden später das ist jetzt nicht wahr
ich kann den bagger steuern
ohne ein
nein aber ich das jetzt zusammen und
es hat auch noch mal oh
oh oh das ist ja sieht gar nicht gut aus
das sieht gar nicht gut aus ich reiste
das komplette ding hier gerade ab
ob man das gebäude hat schon genug
gelitten ich geh jetzt mal ganz kurz
heraus ich komme ja auch nicht raus
nein nein
ja du dich also sonst sturz kann man sie
mal überlebt
das war ich nicht und dass er jetzt
alles zurück dass das war ich auch nicht
allerdings hat euer lesern nun
natürlich auch noch eine dritte map
vorbereitet das ist nämlich eine
einkaufs mall ihr seht schon es läuft
alles deutlich flüssiger hier weil wir
noch nichts zerstört haben damit fangen
allerdings jetzt direkt mal an
die fand ich schon immer kacke hier
vorne steht ein wunderschönes auto das
können wir auch voran
ich hätte gern einmal diesen orangenen
newsletter was ich an dieser map so
extrem feier sind einfach die ganzen
farben also die ganzen reflektionen das
lichtdesign et cetera es einfach und
normal und wir können zudem hat mit dem
physik komplett spiel und alles
irgendwie kaputt machen egal ob das
entgegen die solche bänke sind dass hier
irgendwelche lichter sind die dann sogar
ausgehen oder ob das hier vorne liegen
welche sitzmöglichkeiten sind stühle und
autos können wir gern hat er noch
einfach fahren und damit dann wiederum
auch sachen kaputt machen
es ist so krass
wir haben einfach die
möglichkeit in diesem spiel alles
kaputt zu machen
ich find und da bin ich jetzt nicht
übertreiben ich weiß dass machen
youtuber gerne aber ich finde wirklich
das dass das realistisch spiel es was
zumindest ich je gespielt habe
und guckt euch an mit wie viel liebe zum
detail diese maps auch erschaffen wurden
wie
wunderschön und krass ist teardown bitte
an der stelle mich dass heute ich wieder
das eigentliche ende meine lieben
freunde wenn euch luca spielt teardown
gefallen hat dann das doch gerne einen
daumen hoch unter dem video hier der
abonnierten kanal und klickt auf die
glocke wenn ihr weitere videos in diesem
spiel hier sehen wollt ich habe gesehen
dass piloten das auch mit minecraft
verbunden habt also wenn ihr darauf auch
bock gehabt dass ich mich da mal ein
bisschen rein füchse rhein stürzte dann
schreiben das gerne in die kommentare
und jetzt
[Musik]